Yeah.
I think that the community certainly
didn't see me as any sort of guru
or as any sort of highly
qualified or adept counsellor.
People didn't come to me for counselling
and they didn't treat me in in public
theaters as if i had anything particular.
To offer.
The various debates because i was
working in lismore as a psychiatrist
and i was therefore very much a part
of the dominant paradigm. So i was.
That part of me
that aspect of me being a psychiatrist
they i think they just rejected that.
Fortunately i had. And
alter ego was amusing.
And i think an awful lot of people
really chose to relate to me as
a talented musa i was
only working part time
and so i was able to do a lot of music
and teach at the local community school
and do all of those sorts of things so.
My identity as a psychiatrist wasn't important
except as i said with the policeman
to some extent
and maybe with the townsfolk it gave gave
me a bit of an eye on trade to to move
and talk with those people perhaps
more frequently than other people did
but certainly as far as
the tribe was concerned
that wasn't what they wanted
to know about me even though.
All i have i shouldn't say even though.
I guess one of the reasons that i
was able to survive it all was
that i had a reputation for
being an aunty psychiatrist.
While that i mean is
bizarre in the extreme.
Anti-psychiatry was that interesting.
Deviation that. Occurred
in the late 60s. With.
Ron lange the. The british
psychiatrist who.
Discovered existentialism which
most psychiatrists in the 50s
and 60s.
And before that of course
knew nothing about
but he was a psychiatrist who
read existentialism and.
There were a number of who did but he
importantly then decided of course
that somebody who was paranoid
and who was rejecting.
You know the dominant paradigm
through their paranoia.
Was probably more in contact with reality
than the people who didn't a very
romantic
and sentimental notion with which i was
absolutely captivated as a young psychiatrist
so. You know when various.
People with terrible mental illness.
Even when i was a trainee
expounded on the theories
that.
You know they were likely to be
annihilated by various forces in the
society and their predatory
and capitalist parents.
I mean i was only too willing to hear this
and to hear it as a valid
interpretation of reality
and to therefore see them.
Being dealt with as if they were sick
and invalidated having those
experiences invalidated as definitely.
Part of the problem so.
That was i was quite comfortable with the
label of being an anti psychiatrist even
though i worked with people who
were seriously mentally ill
and. Used drugs and treated them
in fairly conventional ways.
That's not to say that i
didn't try the other way
and the research project i referred to
earlier was one where i really was trying
very hard to deal with man
people as if they were totally
responsible human beings as if they were
creating the sorts of dilemmas they
got into. As authentic portrayals of.
Of their political and
personal reality. But.
Of course it just didn't help them. All
it. It didn't help them certainly.
Validating the paranoid
and delusional experiences of people who
have some sort of mental disorders is
useful. I'm sure it provides
them with some comfort
but actually.
On its own it's really not going to
stop them from probably perishing
or killing somebody else and
and you know i am a doctor
and other people are doctors
or psychiatrists because for
some reason we we decided that.
It's probably a mark of a humane community
if they don't let those people die
or will carry other people away with them.
Because of their strange beliefs
but anyhow i think the fact
that i was known as an anti
psychiatrist and that i'd suffered no.
Not even considerably from my peers.
You know they've failed me in my
exams the first time. But i mean i.
And up at this. You know formidable
and important final exam in psychiatry
with larry you know hair down to my waist
in a duffel coat and.
Probably be in things i mean the next time
i sat for the exam which you're allowed
to do every six months i wore a three
piece suit and had a whisky first
and had my hair cut and past
the exam but i mean the fact
that i was an any psychiatrist
and a high profile one in the media in
the early 70s probably also helped me
to be quite accepted by the tribe.
Up there.
Well i. Yes i think that.
It's very hard to know of course whether.
Niman or whether the fact
that my friend petroff
and i set up a psychiatric service in
lismore is what's responsible for the fact
that there's probably
on a percentage basis.
A few more you know seriously
mentally ill people around him
and then there there would
be around tamworth.
You know when you set up
a psychiatric service.
Then you are you attract a group of
people who are likely to need and use
that service. Well we set up the psych
service in 73 in lismore and him
and gets going in 73 and i think that.
Just time extent those
two things are mixed in.
There's only slightly more genuinely
mentally ill people around
there. Than the. Would be in any other
population but there certainly are.
And the capacity of that community to
tolerate people whose mood swings.
Can create a bit of havoc in their own
lives and those of their loved ones.
It's probably greater out there
and the capacity of the community to
tolerate people who will live almost a feral
sort of life
and have some very disturbed sort of
beliefs is certainly greater than it is
elsewhere and there's no doubt that.
You know there is a greater incidence of
madness but i don't think for a moment
that that's the environment that's
producing the madness i just.
That's a drift adrift of a group of pretty
deviant people into a situation where
they they can survive more easily
and less obviously than than present
practically anywhere else in australia.
Well i mean i only see
that group of ferals who
probably do have schizophrenia.
I've no doubt
that there's a you know a shadow
around a central central group of.
Heroic mad people there is
a shadow of people who are
less heroic and less mad with whom
i'm never coming to any contact
and i think
that their motivation is
something which probably is not
not too different from a basic an archaic
old rejection of the dominant paris.
Time just over ours was 20 years ago
i remember and one of the reasons
that i moved out of nimbin.
Because when i left paradise valley after
a few years after 10 years really.
I moved into a house in town
right in the middle of town.
And one of the ferals began
shitting on my front lawn.
And he wasn't a crazy at all.
He was a drunk and a few other things
but he certainly wasn't mentally
ill or anything like that
and one time after each shat
on the lawn and i went out
and walked by him on my way
out to the car to go to work.
I just said look that is really vile
and i mean he gave me this highly
articulate rave about how it was his lawn.
I mean it was my lawn but i
mean it was his lawn and.
I couldn't cope with
that i just thought i'm i just i'm
not going to be able to live here.
I mean i can hear what he's saying. You
know this is his planet this is his lawn.
He have got if he said he's got
a right to shit on this lawn.
I matter of fact at the time. I hadn't
realized that rights were all bullshit.
I must say that i have
changed in 20 years and all
and some of my ideas have have distilled
into something quite different from what
they were before.
So now if somebody said something to me
about how they had a right to shoot on my
lawn. I probably wouldn't
react the way i did then.
But i was deeply moved by it and i
couldn't think of an argument against it
and i began in my mind thinking of leaving
nimbin because i would have to because.
Simply because i couldn't cope
with him shitting on my lawn
but i thought it was okay
for him to sit on my lawn.
So i would have to go because
i mean i could ask him to go.
I just i remember once on the farm a
fairly feral bloke was living there for a
while and he ran up an $800
phone bill on my phone
and i said to him. This
is unbelievable. You.
You'll have to pay this money
and he saw i can get me money.
And i'm not going to pay it
and and why should i pay it.
You know you've got the phone
and and you've got the money
and i needed to make all
these phone calls to perth
and i remember i burst into tears and i
said well all i can do is ask you to leave.
I can only ask you to leave.
We didn't have a rule where you could
actually send somebody away so
that was a second occasion where you know
when somebody asserted at me
a right to behave in a way
that was seriously impacting on me i
couldn't think of an argument against
that and i moved off the valley.
I've paid the bill and moved off
the valley because he wouldn't
and i moved out of town because this
guy wouldn't not shit on my lawn
and. So. I will.
What was the question again there were.
No.
Yes yes yes yes yes well i
mean i've worked in my own
mind. Now i'm i'm on to a different. I'm
on it i'm on a very different track.
I. I believe that there has
been. A. That's serious.
There is a cataclysms approaching
that people who are spouse the notion
of individual freedom personal freedom
and the right to do things are indeed.
Now i think represent the most
serious danger to the planet.
But whereas i thought before that.
Those sorts of rights were
important for a person to feel
as if they were moving
their world around them.
I now feel of course
that they absolutely run contrary to
a certain human connected with us
which at least i now know is much more
important in me feeling like a worthwhile
human being so groups that are about.
Empowerment and groups that are about.
Self-actualization and groups that are
about personal freedom now i think.
Terrible. I think it's all wrong.
It's rather a see it's a similar problem
to the problem where democracy which is
one hundred fifty years old is a word and
a concept. If you don't count the greeks.
Where democracy. The word
and a vague idea has actually been hijacked
by a group of people who say it means
freedom of choice.
And that without the freedom to choose
there is no such thing as democracy.
Of course democracy in its original
conception had nothing to do with the freedom
of choice particularly nothing to do with.
The idea that you therefore have
to have six things to choose from.
Or you're not operating in a democracy.
I mean that the whole idea
of of bringing freedom
and choice in i guess to simply
bolster materialism and consumerism.
Has simply been a terribly an
incredibly ingenious hijacking of
one of the aspects of democracy
into now what democracy now.
Mean this is that you
have freedom to choose.
Well the idea
that you have to be a
self-determining human being has
been hijacked.
Again by a group of people
who for some reason
don't like to think
that in the final analysis we are
responsible for other people as well as for
ourselves.
Just as responsible for other people as
ourselves i mean we are very vulnerable
creatures for the first
15 years of our life and
and basically for the whole of our life
we do depend upon the goodwill of all of
the other humans on the
planet to survive and.
Things like goodwill and lovingkindness
and all of those sorts of things
actually can disappear entirely.
If you insist
that the most important thing for a human
being to have is self-determination
and free will because
you're really arguing
that you shouldn't be coerced
impacted influenced by
some other person but that's
an absolute nonsense.
You absolutely need
advocacy influence you.
Connectedness all of those things
in order to be a human being.
I'm personally against the
human rights movement.
I have realised in the last
few years that i feel.
And interestingly i've never
joined amnesty and i've
and i've wondered why i
never joined amnesty
and i won't be joining amnesty
because i don't believe
that the human rights movement is the way
out of our terrible problem at the moment
i think the human responsibilities
movement is the way out
and i don't hear anybody talking
about it and i personally.
Terribly uncomfortable about. You
know the freedom to privacy.
This is just.
An absolutely unnatural
state for human beings.
And and most of the things
that have now entered the
discourse as if they are rights.
I think are a very very serious part of
well i can be uncomfortable about the old
word alienation the alienation that
we are building into democracies.
Now we're heading headlong away
from the human connectedness
and the tribal stuff which is just
crucial to the human to human being.
Yes yes.
Being your brother's keeper
in the broadest sense of it.
Yes i am my brother's keeper.
Just as i would want him to
be mine and the notion of.
You know the personal freedom. And autonomy
autonomy what the hell is autonomy.
You can't move without
impacting another human being
whose comfort is critical to yours.
You can't make an action without impacting
another human being whose comfort is
ultimately going to be
incredibly influential on yours.
So you know i find myself now.
Feeling like a totally lone voice about
this whole human rights issue because
certainly i mean when i
when i speak up about it.
You know people look at me as if i'm
some sort of fascist. Maybe i am.
But i'm actually coming from something
which is i think deeply spiritual.
But i'm happy to call
that stuff connectedness.
If spiritual makes people
feel uncomfortable.
I'm on about human connectedness the
interdependence of our of our of our
mind of our mental stuff and of our
mental life and this insistence on.
Individuality personal autonomy choice
and all of those sorts of things i think
is just the natural extension of the
political disasters of the last
hundred years of democracy
and it's re-interpretation and psychology
and it's horrendous eilean asians from.
You know through empiricism
and and behaviorism.
It's it's it's a leap away
from love and compassion which of course.
We only things
that are really important about what
things
are you know. Absolutely absolutely.
The events the tribal events the
concerts the folk clubs the feasts the
dances the rituals
that was what it was about for me growing
old with people who i've known now who
i've now known for 20 years.
Yes all of those things were
the most important things.
As well as for me the actual
reconnecting with growing trees
and
and the season's which i think are
deeply important for all human beings
and. Even though i lived for the first
10 years of my life in the country.
I then spent the next 20 years
during my education in the city
and i had.
I had lost a lot of the the
warmth and the meaning of knowing
that it was a full moon or four
or that the exquisite feeling
that comes over the countryside
after a violent storm
and then the clear eyed lost all
of that stuff you do in the city.
You just not conscious of whether it's
winter or summer or raining or not.
So the human tribal celebrate
tree things were wonderfully
nourishing and then reconnecting
with the trees in the earth.
Was the second thing that. You
know makes the whole thing for me.
Well it's it is what it's what continues
to give my life. It's meaning.
Yes. Oh yeah. Yeah i know well.
Well actually the pictures balls something
that still goes on blue not the
whole sadly as been. Overtaken by.
Some rather violent episodes of life.
As in the last 10 years of
course as alcohol been become.
Is a really made a comeback in the any
alternative community certainly the level of
violence of increased with.
The level of increased alcohol
consumption in the first 10 years or so
when we were all just smoking dope largely
at any sort of tribal gatherings.
They were very much more peaceful
but blue knob hall was of
course a very special venue
and the new year's even the full
moon dances that we had a blue knob.
Always just with the local musicians getting
together getting a repertoire together
for the show.
There were the usual musicians egos
but basically it was often
possible to have 10
or 15 people up on the stage.
And of course we were
all wanting to be heard
but we were all wanting to
hear each other too. So.
Those those were the most precious.
And reinforcing parts of.
Those early years blue knob hall
on a saturday night on a full moon
or new year was just the
most extraordinary event.
What was it.
Now i can't say i can't see.
I what brought us all together unless it
was the same for other people as it was
for me there is a tribe of like minded
people who were not going to follow a
career path which would
continually disrupt their
relationships. You know with each other.
Thats what it was for me i knew
that you know to be a successful psychiatrist
i would have to make a number of
career moves that would be geographical
and i would lose my group over
and over again so i think that.
I would hazard a guess that
really all of the people
that arrived up there with the view
that they were going to stay there
and not make the usual geographical
moves that go with contemporary life.
I'd say they all were there for
that same tribal reason i wanted to make a
connection with a group of people whose
faces they would all know.
All the time and grow old with those
people even if i said i went there so
that they could get into alternative power
or so they could get into anything else.
I really feel
that it was the desire to to have
this non-wrestling primary group
that would stay still.
That took us all where a
sunny story about an image yes yes.
We're before we'd all
moved up onto the farm.
We used to go up there for the holidays
and of course we'd all had mushrooms
i guess during the festival and
that sort of thing
but i think it was the very next
holidays we all found ourselves up there
that would've been christmas 73 say.
And so the whole of the group of.
Yes the 12 of us who bought land in our
kids. Three or four kids were up there.
And we were just arriving in dribs and
drabs as we'd driven up from sydney
and the mushrooms were out in
the cowshed with everywhere.
And so we were going to have our for
everyone was going to drop some
mushrooms and most of us.
Had had some mushrooms during the festival
but whether there was one wonderful
woman who had never had any mushrooms
and so we all took the mushrooms and
all got into the various states
that you get into. When
you're tripping on mushrooms.
And we all noticed about an hour later
that this wonderful woman
had grabbed the broom.
And she was dashing around the paddock
where we were all lying in various states
or or whatever
and she was sweeping the
cowpats into little piles.
And at this point i
should say she's a virgo.
And she was always the tidiest person
in the commune she was in charge of the
washing up and the cooking and
all of this sort of thing
and she had proceeded to tidy up
the cowshed in the paddock and
when i said to our what the
hell are you doing. She said.
When's this bloody stuff
going to start to work.
With this the rest of us sort of
collapsed. You know how deep.
And i think she realised
that it was working.
Yes. You've asked me what i
think about niman and drugs.
The dark side of nim and the.
It's now narcotics that's a very strong
scene in nimbin well obviously you know
from the amount of time i've spent talking
to you about marijuana and mushrooms
and
and those sorts of things for me the the
drug taking part of niman was important.
So i'm not at all surprised.
Of course that there
is now a very obvious.
Drug culture in nimbin and not surprised
that of course it is.
That rather than just being marijuana and.
Mushrooms
and those sorts of things which of course
are harmful i'm not suggesting they're
not but rather than it being those
things. It's now narcotics.
To be truthful i believe there's
just one very simple explanation.
But it's not an opinion that
would be easy to to prove
but.
I think it is almost
entirely relates to the
way the police actually
feel about people like me
and about all of us who've come up
there. I think that the police.
Well let's start a step back.
I think envy is one of the most.
Common human feelings i
mean it's not. It's not a.